so hopefully you can all see my screen
right now
and me great
um that's amazing so uh
in in just a few minutes in five minutes
by the way if you've got questions
uh feel free to type them in the chat as
we go and then we're going to address
them all at the end
together so we're not going to interrupt
to take questions
but um so i'm going to talk about vpc
encryption and some of the problems we
saw for that
and and some of the big problems and
some of the small problems because i
think they give a
uh a really good flavor of of of the
kind of challenges we deal with
um if if you're not familiar with
how we do encryption on amazon web
services uh we've got a pretty thorough
encryption stack you know we're a big
a big cloud provider and as you'd expect
a lot of our customers
um want encryption in all sorts of areas
and we've got
client-side encryption tools we've got
key management services we've got
encryption for data and transit and
we've got
encryption for data at rest and so on
but here i'm just going to focus on our
network encryption
so uh we've got network encryption baked
into a bunch of places
um and we we obviously use tls
and ssl and quick just like everybody
does in fact we have our own
implementations
of all three of those protocols and we
have a vpn service
that uses the ipsec protocol um that's a
well standardized protocol
but we also have um kind of in-house
custom built uh encryption layers
and so we've got vpc encryption where
if you launch an ec2 instance so that's
like a virtual machine
um that is of the right generation and
has the right hardware in it
uh all traffic between any two instances
of that type
it's just encrypted customer doesn't
need to do anything there's nothing to
enable it
it just happens um if a customer
peers two vpcs so they've got a virtual
private cloud
in one of our regions and in another and
if they appear those
the traffic between those is also
encrypted and then our physical network
uh anytime anytime we've got a link
that leaves any area that we don't
physically control so like for example
between
two data centers or even between two
cages in the same color
or across continents um it's protected
by
uh physical network encryption and and
we had a hand
in actually developing this encryption
like you know bottom to top from
specifying how the protocols work
uh on the wire to actually implementing
it and getting it working in silicon
um which you know to me iclass is a big
challenge
for vpc encryption this is this all
happens kind of
in our physical hardware uh using our
aws nitro system so we've got these
embedded
cards uh that are like physically in the
box
and we uh and their their arm-based
systems
that are doing all sorts of hardware and
virtualization for us
they help us virtualize storage but they
also help us virtualize the network
and there's uh silicon in there that
does aes
you know at line rate and can encrypt
the traffic
um as we're sending it but it you know
just it's not as simple as plugging in a
card and buying the silicon and
hooking it all together and getting
everything to work right it actually
took
quite quite a lot of effort of
designing those encryption protocols how
it's actually going to be laid out on
the wire and
formally modeling and verifying all that
to make sure that it's secure that we've
got the right security properties
and then um a lot of tedious work
optimizing that packet pipeline
you know making sure that we pre-fetch
packets and encrypt them and
in this really robust well-optimized
pipeline that's not going to degrade
customer performance
uh not not an easy problem and we pay
attention to lots of little
you know lots of little details like for
example
we have to encapsulate all of this in a
in a udp packet
at the end so that all of this is
friendly like existing network
technologies like float hashing
and doesn't just uh break existing
uh network assumptions um you know this
this is the kind of effort that takes
a lot of people over a long period of
time
coordinating across a lot of groups at
amazon you know we've got annapurna who
make
and make the networking cards part is
part of amazon we've got all the folks
who design the cryptography all the
network engineers
all the systems engineers and software
developers who help with the
optimization so that's like a big
problem but an example of a small
problem that we solve right is like well
how do we actually get the keys anywhere
right so to encrypt all this traffic
uh we obviously need to have keys that
the senders and the receivers share
right the sender encrypts with that key
and the receiver uh decrypts
with that key at our scale you can't
really do pairwise key negotiation just
wouldn't work you know the
the numbers grow by by a square factor
and that's just way way too big
uh way too quickly so we actually have
to get the keys but we want to follow
the principle of least privilege right
we don't actually want
anything other than the devices doing
encryption and decryption to know those
keys
in particular we don't want some central
magic system that just has all the keys
in it because that would be a very rich
uh target for for some kind of attack
right and then you wouldn't you would
never want that
so an example of how we solve this
problem
in kind of a small way is something we
call rumors
right so what we do is we have separate
systems that distribute what we call
rumors
or like pre-secret material and they
just distribute this
to all of the aws nitro cards which can
then
combine these rumors into actually
knowing the secret key and i love this
example because it's
it's really really simple this doesn't
take a lot of lines of code it's not a
hard pattern to do
but it means that if any of our central
systems ever have a problem
uh or ever targeted for attack they
actually don't know the secret key
uh it gives us this really nice
isolation property you know many many
systems and
different operators and different
peoples and so on would have to be
targeted um for that secret key to be
revealed
very very simple solution you don't see
it in a lot of places it's example of
like just solving a small problem
creatively
uh to get our customers an interesting
solution so that's
that's my big problem and my small
problem and
if you've got questions about either of
those i can answer them later
and i'm going to hand off now to
whoever's next because i forgot
i think i'm next i'm good oh cool
let me also do the hardest part of this
presentation is the screen share
can you guys see my screen
yes all right
cool cool i'm sure you guys have
questions about con's presentation start
posting them in don't hold on to them
you can
put them in the chat box and we will
actually come to them towards the end
uh i'm ali khan i'm actually the senior
manager i'm the only person who's not a
principal here
so i have a serious imposter syndrome
thing going on right now
so i'm actually a manager at aws i've
been here about three years
uh my team is really split into two
halves uh one of them
is internet major match and the other
one is sdn controllers
and i'll talk about both of these and
how they work together for aws customers
start off with a fun fact this is the
first slide that i've built in three
years
we don't do i mean if you don't know
this already i'm like we don't do any
slides
in aws or amazon in general you know we
just do nothing
like it's all us
that game goes so well
we can hear you now ellie all right
sorry about that guys
yeah okay cool
can you guys see the screen again
yeah yes okay so yeah i was saying that
these are
these uh six page narratives that we
write are very similar to research paper
very specific format
uh and uh very data driven
very very similar to research paper the
only difference is that you actually get
your peer review right there and then
so you bring it to a meeting the first
20 30 minutes people just read them
read the talk and the 30 minutes of
discussion and you get your peer review
there and then as to whether it's
getting accepted or rejected so
that's a pretty interesting concept uh
and uh i
i enjoy it it's liberating for me not to
have to do powerpoints
okay moving on to the aws van
infrastructure another fun fact i mean
aws has
amazon generally has a different name
for everything you don't call
call this van and we don't call the
controllers sdn uh i guess because we
start
way before these things become super
cool so we have a different name for all
of these things but yeah i'm trying to
use terminology that you guys
would be familiar with our wide
infrastructure is really divided into
uh four different uh components one of
them is regenerate our
aws regions uh
and uh we have hundreds of these hops as
well uh pops are
of two types so we have two different
distinct types of pops
standardized but the two different types
one of those is actually what connects a
region to the internet
and to the rest of the world and the
other one is what connects
uh generally our edge hosted services so
an example of an edge hosted service
would be cloud front
which is a cdn or s3 which is a storage
layer
or a global accelerator which is a
global load balancer
and direct connect which is a private
connectivity that amazon provides from
your private data center
into aws regions so we've got these
hundreds of pops
24 regions all of these are connected
through the connectivity is provided
through a global backbone so all east
west traffic across regions
uh from the pops coming back into the
regions goes over our
uh global backbone and eventually
whenever we have to deliver bits to our
customers they go over the transit and
pairing uh connection
so uh we've got a huge uh transit
appearing appearing footprint all across
the world
with many different providers and
that's really that footprint is what my
team focuses on
and the technologies in my
oh man i should be talking about the
internet
the internet is angry with me saying
that it's just broken
so yeah i need to bring some of my
controllers into my
my place if this breaks again i'll
probably just move over to my
uh my mobile network because uh uh the
wire line one
is not seem to be working very well uh
but you enter that way i mentioned you
do three types of intermittent wave
events your synthetic wavelengths going
from regions of pops towards customer
destinations on the internet we have
similar kind of synthetic measurements
coming into our regions and pops
uh we also have passive measurements
where we look at other services and what
they are seeing so something like s3 or
cloud front and look at tcp software
parameters to see you know
all of a sudden
this has become a live demo of network
reliability
[Music]
hey john um do you want to take over and
we can come back to ollie um in a few
minutes
absolutely
one second
hey guys okay
hopefully 18t serves us better sorry
about that
all right can you give me a screen now
yep okay if this breaks again this is
bad karma guys because i'm like i really
switched over to the atd network so
let's see how this goes
uh so i was saying we had uh uh
synthetic movements uh data plane
moments going from regions and
pops to destinations are coming back we
have passive measurements that we look
at other services and what they are
observing
uh for internet impairments and then
finally we also look at control plane
and that's a very important piece of our
uh
monitoring story so with all of our
transit appearing footprint across the
world
we have a very unique vantage point to
look into uh what
what the world is seeing from an amazon
prefix perspective and
what we are seeing from the rest of the
world we also have uh
feeds bgp feeds coming from external
networks uh
intermediate type of connectors to our
customers uh that tell us if there's any
anomalous behavior of
amazon prefixes uh being propagated uh
uh on the internet
so active and passive control and data
plane all of these are
uh are part of this these measurements
actually are what inform our sdm
controller so this is the foundation
and whenever whenever in steady state we
see a path that could be better for a
particular prefix on the internet
that is vended to the sdn controllers or
if there's a fault that is happening on
the internet what is the port where is
it happening
that information is fed into the steam
controllers and sdn controllers are done
the ones that actually make at the c and
about you know
where traffic should be redoubted to uh
in steady state to just provide the best
uh performance to our customers and
under uh
failure or a fault i'm like where should
it be redoubted too
as team controllers have actually pretty
interesting tasks because they have to
optimize traffic across many different
dimensions uh like
availability uh reachability then also
performance which is latency jitter
uh throughput cost dollar cost of
routing
uh at our scale uh it's actually a
pretty important factor to consider as
well and finally business can change
like comment rates or
those things cells have to be affected
into this thing uh
as you can see some of these are
actually even uh conflicting with each
other
so your most uh performant network might
not be the most available in certain
geographies
uh if you're getting higher uh best the
best latency generally the cost also
goes up so
there's like this is a very interesting
mix of you know how do you optimize
across these dimensions that actually be
competing with each other
uh the goal these things work together
the goal is to optimize the connectivity
experience
uh of our customers and this is a full
feedback loop so the steam controllers
when they make it the sea and then enact
it in the network
actually go back to the internet
measurements and see if the decision
that they took is actually making
the connectivity experience better the
problem that they were trying to solve
is it
even solved and is or is there any other
connectivity improvement that is still
impacting the customers
i'll talk briefly about challenges
technical challenges uh the big ones
lots of data on the internet environment
side lots and lots of data
that has to be ingested globally uh that
has to be collected ingested globally
from our own services
uh external services uh then we have to
the entertainment environment has to
make a lot of influences on the data
there's a lot of information theory
machine learning that happens over there
on you know there is something wrong on
the internet what is wrong and where is
it wrong
all of those sort of like the temporal
and spatial uh
elements have to be fed into the sdn
controllers uh
the sdn controllers make sorting the cns
optimized across multiple dimensions as
we talked about earlier
and then assign controllers are also
responsible for implementing these
decisions uh
in this global network uh uh with
consistency and correctness so it has to
be
the decision journey start off with the
local context but they need to be
propagated all over the world
and uh just making sure that any any
decision
that you're making is not uh just moving
the problem around so you just
this congestion somewhere you just don't
want to move it around and keep
oscillating just moving that condition
around so
it has to be consistent they have to be
correct in terms of you know when you
make it the cn
you're not overriding it uh by some
other component uh we've got multiple
sdm controllers which each become an
application on top of the same substrate
of
foundational services that we have uh
but uh
you need to make sure that they're not
sort of shipping on each other's stores
so there's some correctness guarantees
that we have to provide
and eventually like i said it's a full
feedback system so you go back to the
entire way events to see that you
actually are providing
solving the problem that you're trying
to solve whether it's to put traffic on
the most
performant path or it to bypass a
impairment that you just detected on the
internet uh the interesting part of it
is this is all has to be done in real
time
so real time is like five minutes or
less everything that i mentioned over
here you want to do it very very quickly
and you want to uh make those decisions
and invent them in the network very
quickly as well
uh my last slide i want to talk about my
team also in terms of people
so um all of my team my journey
basically three different types of skill
sets one of them is software engineers
these are your core
strong distributed systems and systems
people
algorithm data structures people then
you've got scientists you have three
different types of scientist families in
amazon and reach out to me or kelly or
jarvie for about you know what these
families are but it's different types of
scientists families but
these are your sort of mathematics and
statistics and machine learning folks
which are making
uh the algorithms and proving them with
production traffic that these are these
are things that
uh that would actually work in
production the way we want them to
within the time and space uh constraints
that we have
on these algorithms and finally we've
got network engineers these are
networking experts who would tell us you
know how our particular decision that
we're making
be impacted and implemented inside of an
asex let's say
on a particular networking platform what
are the existing protocols that are
that are available or options that are
available to implement these decisions
and whether which one is the right one
and that can have a big impact on
what the scientists are developing or
what the software
engineers are implementing here's my
sales pitch
sick commerce are right in this school
in the middle of all of this you guys
have all of these expertise
uh we already got a few of you in our
team and uh
luck to have more so this is can't end
the presentation without a sales pitch
so
fun fact and with a fun fact since we
started talking maybe more than this
because i was supposed to take five
minutes but i think i took more so
nearly 600 million into the environments
have been collected since the start of
this presentation
by our infrastructure
please feel free to post questions and i
will hand it over to
john thanks ali stealing some of my
thunder there
i can't forgive you
okay uh so
can everybody see my slides
i hope yeah great um
so thanks ellie yeah i'm john evans i'm
a network development engineer
i've been at aws for a couple of years
and um
i focus on network availability and
performance engineering
um and i'm gonna try and highlight some
of the challenges that we
some of the challenges that we try and
solve in aws
in that area um now
we deal with a lot of data so i thought
i'd measure the progress through my
slides in terms of the volume of data
that we're generating in the
in the network at the moment um but just
to give
give a little bit of suspense i'm not
going to tell you what the units are
until we get to the end of the
presentation so we're going to start on
xero and then we're going to
incrementally work through the
presentation and then i'll do the big
reveal
um so
whoops my slide seems to be changing on
their own
um so what problem is it that we're
solving
um and i'd express it in terms of
answering two questions
um the first one is how do we measure
the network performance we're delivering
in terms that emit
that represent our customers experience
that sounds uh sounds relatively
straightforward but
we've got many many different customers
with many many different services
we have them in local geographies in
spread geographies um
doing things that are real time doing
things that are offline
um so you know
that is a non it sounds like a simple
question but actually it's it's it's
fairly non-trivial um
and then once we've defined it how do
you measure that
um globally at scale
um the the second question uh that we
try and answer is once we've got that
measure once we've got that definition
how do we maximize our network's uh
availability at delivering that that
defined performance
and this is a um this is a data analysis
problem
and we solve it by whoops i i'm
sorry my slides progressing
automatically
um so we solve this with uh um we solve
this with
uh by analyzing the the huge volumes of
data that we get from the network
that we have different systems of
producing data
so passive monitoring which we get from
the devices themselves
active monitoring from synthetic traffic
that we put on the network in order to
measure the performance
we have different types of data we have
metric data which expresses performance
we have event data that expresses
changes of state
we have flow data that expresses um uh
that describes
traffic information i'm gonna i i
guess orient this around metrics um but
if my if powerpoint will behave um
uh so after we've collected that data we
have to transform it in order to make it
usable
uh and then oh uh
and then um uh but then we look for
um uh indications and signals that
the network's not performing as we
expect um and so this is where we're
really looking for anomalies and looking
for anomaly detection in that data
in order to give us some indication of
where where things
you know aren't delivering on that
performance
now as you can imagine uh with a lot of
data
um you get a lot of anomalies uh anomaly
doesn't mean
uh that you've got a problem uh uh but
it may
uh and so in order to make sense of the
uh anomalies that we
um uh that we generate we then have to
uh correlate those and try and identify
you know in all of that in in all of
that information try and identify what's
causal
um so we have um you know we have
systems that deal with anomaly detection
we have other systems that deal with uh
uh correlation and
and and causation and the outputs of
those
uh essentially our actions um and
um we have other systems that take those
actions
take those triggers and actually look to
solve the problems on the network
without causing impact
to our customers so
let's let's give an example let's
imagine that we've got a um let's
imagine that we've got a network device
we detect that that network device is
having a problem which may be
through passive monitoring through
active monitoring or a combination of
both
quite uh quite frequently we would
uh proactively uh take that device out
of service
we would shift the traffic away from it
before we do so that we don't uh
cause customer impact we then
take the device out of service we then
remediate the problem
uh once we've immediated the problem and
confirmed it's working we'll then
bring the device back into service and
shift the traffic
back onto the device so our goal
you know in all of this is that we're
able to try and detect problems before
they're customer impacting and
try and fix them without a human
actually
being involved
so now the big reveal um we i mentioned
we do that by processing the data we get
from the network and in the time i've
been talking to you
uh if i'm keeping to time uh we've uh
collected six billion network
observations
so put another way that's six trillion
network observations in a day
uh that we um that we process um
and obviously that creates um you know
that creates challenges
uh we're fortunate that we've got um
we've got a set of services
um that are scaled to deal with that uh
aws glue aws athena and
but also that we've got a um a good
ecosystem of
uh um of data scientists research
scientists
network development engineers and
software development engineers in order
to try and tackle these problems
that was everything i had
look forward to your questions thank you
all right i think next up is me
let me uh also try to make sure i get
this part right
and let me take over john screen sharing
all right hopefully you can see my
screen
uh hi my name is andrew dickinson i'm
going to be talking about
some of the challenges of designing a
software defined network for
project kuiper
if i can advance my slides that would be
wonderful
before i jump into talking about project
kuiper
let me tell you a bit about myself i
started amazon in 2004 when i was fresh
out of college with a degree
in computer engineering in 2007
i joined a little project working on
cloud computing called amazon ec2
you might have heard of it on the ec2
team i had an opportunity
to design and build a lot of the
technology that makes amazon virtual
private cloud or vpc possible
work with calm on some of that stuff the
scale of ec2
makes problems like vpc very exciting uh
there's there's no textbook solution for
how to build a software-defined network
that can operate at the scale that we're
operating at
uh in fact i uh believe that uh the the
vpc network is the uh largest
multi-tenant software defined network
anywhere in the world
now building a system like that at this
at that sort of scale
it's a team effort and i've had a chance
to learn from and work with
some of the smartest people in the
industry after working on vpc for more
than a decade i was
longing for those early days in ec2 and
i decided to join amazon's project
kuiper
if you're not familiar project kuiper is
amazon's long-term initiative to provide
low-latency
high-speed broadband connectivity to
unserved and underserved communities
around the world
by launching a constellation of low
earth orbit satellites
uh you know we've heard so many stories
lately about people who are unable to do
the job or complete school work
uh because they don't have reliable
internet at home and there's still
too many places where broadband access
is unreliable or where it doesn't exist
at all
kuiper's going to change that projects
like kuiper are one of the things that i
love about amazon
it's bold and ambitious you know
building satellites
and launching them into orbit requires a
team of highly interdisciplinary
engineers
i'm working with people uh with
specializations in solar panels and
batteries
uh thrusters and space uh mechanisms
microwave rf and antenna designs
project hyper depends on all of those
specializations to be successful
but our customers don't see them you
know our customers don't care how
efficient the solar panels on our
satellites are or
they don't care how smooth the thrusters
and the satellites are they care about
the network
we want to delight our customers with a
broadband experience that's
indistinguishable from terrestrial
broadband offerings
actually for many of our customers we
want kuiper's broadband's offerings to
be
better than what they can get from a
local terrestrial isp
the kuiper network is a software-defined
network
but we've got some unique challenges
that most sdns don't have to tackle for
example
most with most software-defined networks
the network itself
is relatively stable and the engineering
challenge for that sdn is
how to get packets from one point to
another across that topology
project kuiper has an extra twist the
network itself is physically moving
our satellites are in low earth orbit
they're
zipping by at 27 000 kilometers per hour
to provide continual coverage to our
customers we plan to launch over 3 200
satellites and a constellation around
earth at altitudes around 600 kilometers
at those speeds and altitudes a customer
can
see any given satellite for only a few
minutes at a time
and they'll need to continually have
their network connection hand off from
one satellite
to another so let's look at that in a
little bit more detail
at 600 kilometers above earth we're
dealing with
at least two milliseconds of a flight
time between the satellites
and our customers and that's just
physics due to speed of light or rf in
this case
over that sort of distance we want to
keep latency in jitter low
so let's think about this transition
from one satellite to the next
even if the outgoing satellite stops
transmitting at the exact moment that
the incoming satellite starts
transmitting
the customer's equipment at their home
needs to
keep listening to that old satellite for
a few milliseconds to receive the data
that's in the air
between the old satellite and that
customer equipment
before that equipment quickly turns and
starts receiving data from the new
satellite
now that's crazy but let's keep going
we also need to handle uplink data from
our customers
so during this transition it'd be really
nice if that moment in time when the old
satellite stops
transmitting towards the customer if
that aligned with the time
when the satellite stops receiving from
the customer
what this means is that we want our
customers equipment to start
sending data to the new satellite just
ahead of that transition time
literally shooting into the dark uh at
the satellite before it gets there
this is just one small example of the
challenges that amazon faces
on a daily basis i love these sorts of
challenges and i love that amazon is
willing to take bold and ambitious bets
like this
thanks everyone next up we're going to
take
questions i see that you've already been
typing them in the